Tara you are quite a talented mimic you  do a very good very good  dama don't you do that oh you do that to  do that yeah okay all right what do I do  you do Gollum I think that Donald no no  I don't do Donald I could I do a good  goal of impression yeah we have a clip  of it let's take a look at this  I think Amazon's actually you should  cost for the Amazons actually doing the  new a remake it's on my dating their  fault check it out you should definitely  go for God rate on your dating problems  and and do you do all that time was gone  do you do a gone after that no I've got  to get naked I've got to get on the  floor you've got to shave your head  first you gonna look like a yeah I've  been going there I know when I'm beat